salut bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode
d'interview à la table imaginez vous
habitez dans un petit village prê de
Poitier vous êtes fasciné par la magie
la magie des cartes mais aussi la triche
et vous terminez à Las Vegas accompagné
du plus grand tricheur de tous les temps
Richard Marcus pour faire un spectacle
de démonstration de triche c'est
exactement ce qui a vécu Maurice Douda
que je vais recevoir aujourd'hui vous
l'aviez peut-être déjà vu sur la chaîne
il est spécialisé dans la magie des
cartes plus spécialement la triche son
histoire est incroyable bon Maurice toi
tu as un invité un petit peu différent
parce qu'on se connaît depuis des années
toi et moi mais je vais faire comme si
je connaissais rien de toi parce que je
connais les histoires mais je connais
pas forcément toujours ce qu'il y a
derrière ce que tu as pensé de ça ce que
tu as ressenti là-dessus donc je vais en
apprendre c'est sûr néanmoins je vais te
poser des questions dont j'ai déjà la
réponse mais c'est pas très grave parce
que les personnes qui nous écoutent ou
qui neous regardent l'ont pas quand et
comment même tu as découvert la magie
déjà télévision euh
1984 85 José garciimort gerérard Majax
voilà c'est les magiciens de mon enfance
et là je découvre à cette époque-là
l'émission il y a un truc puis dans
l'émission Récré 2 avec gaet en Bloom le
déclic on va dire et quand tu découvres
ça donc toi tu le découvres en tant que
spectateur et tu te dis quoi tu te dis
je veux savoir comment ils font je veux
faire pareil ou juste c'est fascinant ce
truc ça m'interloque un peu quoi je me
dis tiens c'est rigolo je comprends pas
alors je vais chercher à comprendre
alors évidemment les revues de mon âge p
gadget pxou magazine on parle d'un monde
où il y a pas internet ah bah là là il y
a pas du tout Internet et puis ça
démarre comme ça et et lors d'un mariage
où mes parents avaient été invités il y
avait un magicien qui faisait passer des
à travers la table ça ça m'a rendu fou
c'est la première fois où tu es
confronté à une sorte d'effets spéciaux
mais dans la vraie vie quoi ça là tu as
plus l'écran où tu te dis bon bah c'est
de l'autre côté de la caméra c'est dans
la vraie vie ça rend fou ça ah ça ça
rend fou ça énerve ça t'empêche de
dormir et puis au final bah tu veux
passer de l'autre côté du miroir quoi
ouais c'est ça toi tu as longtemps fait
du close-up pour des soirées privées
d'ailleurs tuen réalis toujours mais je
parle de ça parce que c'est comme ça
qu'on s'est rencontré fin des années
2000 c'était en 2009 la première fois je
crois tu en étais où dans ta vie de
magicien à ce moment-là c'était quoi ton
quotidien en tant que magicien est-ce
que tu en vivais est-ce que tu
pratiquais souvent c'était quoi alors je
pratiquais souvent mais j'avais une
double activité je travaillais agent
secret agent secret pas du tout non pas
du tout non ça commence par agent aussi
mais c'est agent d'approvisionnement ça
fait un peu moins rêver mais je
travaillais ouais dans la fonction
publique et j'essayais de bah d'allier
les deux les deux boulots en même temps
ce qui n'était pas évident et puis au
bout d'un moment il y en a un qui a pris
le pas sur l'autre donc à l'époque
c'était ouais c'était un peu la course
et puis c'est devenu tellement la course
que mon épouse m'a pas mis le couteau
sous la gorge pour me donner le choix
mais il y avait un peu de ça quand même
quoi elle m'a dit bon va falloir choisir
quoi donc après ben je me suis lancé en
tant que professionnel c'est c'est c'est
à la fois une épée de Damocles le tu vas
devoir choisir mais à la fois aussi un
encouragement ça veut ça sous-entend
aussi que si tu choisis la magie elle te
suit elle te elle te soutient là-dedans
complètement tout à fait ça par contre
elle m'a toujours soutenu et justement
elle m'a aidé à franchir le pas ouais et
puis c'était plus fort que moi tu sais
comme quand on a quelque chose qui nous
démange ah on dit j'ai bien envie
d'essayer j'ai un peu peur mais bon bah
c'est sortir de sa zone de confort tout
simplement et je voilà je suis sorti de
ma zone de confort pour aller voir ce
qui se passait un petit peu plus loin et
puis et puis ça m'a pas donné envie de
faire un retour en arrière j'ai voulu
continuer on va pas tarder à parler de
trich et de Las Vegas mais justement à
cette période là donc toujours 2009 tu
vois 2010 à la limite est-ce que la
triche c'est quelque chose qui
t'intéresse est-ce que pas du tout
est-ce que pour toi ça représente juste
une partie de de l'art magique c'est
c'est c'est parce que ça va devenir
quelques années plus tard un pan très
important de ta vie mais à ce moment-là
est-ce que ça l'est est-ce qu'il y a des
prémisses ou pas du tout alors oui parce
que je je m'intéresse déjà enfin je suis
déjà cartoman à cette à ce moment-là et
en fait j'ai découvert quand j'étais à
dos dans la rue un joueur de bon tau un
vrai joueur de bon to et là c'est là que
je me suis intéressé à la triche et je
me suis intéressé au bonau
ais mois j'avais une quinzaine d'années
le bonau pour pour pour ceux qui savent
pas ce que c'est vous savez c'est par
exemple il y a trois cartes deux cartes
rouges et une carte noire admettons et
la personne les mélange et il faut
retrouver où est la carte rouge c'est ça
le bon ouais exactement on le retrouve
sous toutes ses formes tu sais avec les
gobelets les palais enfin il y a une
multitude de bonau et voilà je je
m'intéresse à la triche à partir de ce
moment-là donc ça reste dans un coin de
ma tête mais j'ai toujours dans l'idée
de d'essayer de les jeux de dé de
trouver des solutions pour pouvoir
détourner un petit peu et surtout
augmenter le gain vers moi si je dois
jouer avec quelqu'un pas forcément
arnaquer les copains mais il y a quand
même quelque chose pour le fun comme ça
qui me qui m'intéresse j'ai l'impression
que la triche elle ramène un truc qu'on
a un petit peu moins qu'on pratique la
magie alors toi tu es un magicien
accompli mais tu as cette spécialité là
Descartes je je trouve que quand on
triche peut-être je m'illusionne
moi-même mais peut-être on a un shoot
d'AD adrénaline vachement différent de
quand on fait un tour de magie quand on
fait un tour de magie la règle elle est
implicite je trouve pour le spectateur
et le magicien que tu es de on va suivre
les directives du magicien et on admet
qu'il va se passer quelque chose
d'impossible et on s'y attend même il y
a cette promesse là quand tu triches bah
on ne sait pas forcément que tu triches
et tu dois pas te faire prendre et et il
y a pas encore le contrat implicite
peut-être tu vas le démontrer à la fin
parce que toi tu tu tu fais du spectacle
donc tu vas dire regarde il s'est passé
ça tu vois mais mais je pense que c'est
une adrénaline très différente de faire
un tour de magie ou faire un truc de
triche où le contrat est moins clair non
carrément il y a le côté bah il y a le
côté risque évidemment le geste doit
être certain prêt très travaillé et
évidemment il faut que ce soit invisible
donc il y a ce côté ouais poussé
d'adrénaline qui fait que le spectateur
en face le joueur en face ne sait pas
qu'on va tricher et effectivement ça se
fait sur une fraction de seconde il faut
que ce soit parfait mais un petit peu qu
même quand on fait de la magie aussi moi
je le dis souvent je dirais que le
magicien est peut-être un tricheur
honnête c'est un tricheur honnête c'est
ça c'est le contrat éclair ouais un
magicien qui aurait mal tourné aller
savoir mais en en tout cas la frontière
est très fine entre les deux quoi je
trouve donc toi tu avais l'objectif déjà
en 2009 de faire de la magie ton métier
à pleintemps ta femme t'aide à basculer
dans cette décision là dans ton premier
spectacle je me souviens c'était une
sorte de one Magic Show on va dire une
espèce de de one man issu de magie donc
là ça traité de tout et cetera mais là
on va parler de ton deuxième spectacle
est-ce que tu peux nous présenter déjà
tricheur c'est quoi ce spectacle donc
l'idée c'était d'écrire une histoire et
d'en faire un spectacle puis ensuite de
venir greffer les effets magiques pour
que ça soit un spectacle de magie bien
sûr mais un spectacle de magie
théâtralisé et puis est venu à un moment
donné j'ai dit tiens j'aimerais bien
écrire l'histoire vraie du plus grand
tricheur de tous les temps et euh tout
en étant à Poitier tout en étant à
Poitier et là on a cherché et on est
tombé sur Richard Marcus toujours en vie
euh qui a triché pendant 25 ans dans les
plus grands casinos du monde qui ramassé
on estime sa fortune à peu près 5
millions de dollars et il s'est retiré
euh comme un boxeur serait invaincu bien
il s'est retiré sans s'être fait
attraper Richard Marcus est-ce que pour
toi c'est un magicien à sa façon ah oui
parce que c'est un oui oui c'est un
artiste hein à part entière là-dessus
hein il est à droit avec ses mains on
pourrait dire c'est un prestigitateur
donc il va très très vite donc lui il
travaillait beaucoup avec les jetons
donc cas in il fait le geste au bon
moment placé sur un temps où il faut que
ce soit pas visible quoi donc oui moi
pour moi c'est un c'est un magicien
ouais c'est clair donc lui il a triché
dans tous les casinos du monde ou
seulement à Vegas je sais pas trop Vegas
Atlantic City renult là où il y avait
des casinos et puis en Europe il il a
fait un peu de l'Europe aussi ouais il a
fait de l'Europe londr Moné Carlo et et
c'est intéressant là tu disais tricher
avec les jetons beaucoup c'est vrai que
moi quand on parle de triche
spontanément et je pense que les gens
qui nous écoutent c'est pareil on pense
à une triche de carte quoi tu vas
changer de carte et cetera mais il y a
d'autres chemins possibles en fait il y
a ouais il y a d'autres chemins
possibles lui sa spécialité c'était
vraiment avec les jetons alors les
jetons par contre sur n'importe quel jeu
de casino c'estàdire aussi bien
blackjack bakara roulette craps
n'importe où dès qu'il pouvait même
choper des jetons à droite à gauche sur
la table subtiliser faire croire qu'il
avait mis plus faire croire qu'il avit
mis moins voà etchanger c'est ça
exactement créer une illusion d'optique
décaler des jetons vers l'avant pour pas
qu'on voit un jeton dessous et puis
moment donné faire un change de pile de
jeton c'était c'était très très fin
c'est légendaire les tricheurs est-ce
que un tricheur d'après toi est est un
peu
frustré de ne pas être reconnu à sa
juste valeur parce qu'il a créé des
techniques il a créé une manière de
faire il a il a un culot est-ce que
est-ce que Richard Marcus par exemple
aujourd'hui est heureux que son histoire
soit mise en avant le problème des
tricheurs qui se font prendre c'est
parce que c'est peut-être de la faute de
leur enfin c'est leur ego qui fait que
ils se font prendre oui ce sont des
artistes un
il doit avoir un public quo c'est ça lui
ne s'est jamais fait attraper parce
qu'il était très très discret c'était
quelqu'un qui qui faisait un coup de
coups dans un casino et il partait
ailleurs et pas sur des grosses sommes
ouis donc il voulait pas se faire
repérer c'était
pas flur un flambeur quoi celui qui veut
faire parler un peu trop de lui
généralement se fait attraper donc on
peut supposer que Richard Marcus par
exemple allait prendre de l'argent un
casino reparter le casino n'avait même
pas compris qui c'est éit fait entre
guillemets un peu braqué par par un
tricheur parce qu'en terme de chiffre
c'était pas très visible et et du coup
personne se posa de question quoi tout à
fait c'était il a juste perdu contre un
joueur point c'est ça exactement et
c'était des petites sommes à la limite
si enfin quand il faisait un coup de
bluff comme ça c'était 1000 dollars donc
il doublait sa mise il repait avec 2000
sur un casino à Vegas c'est c'est rien
quoi mais plusieurs fois dans la soirée
dans divers casinos et variés on va dire
hein alors 4 5 fois ça fait 4 5000 et
puis 5 ou si fois dans la semaine ouais
ça fait des ça fait des bonnes semaines
ça fait des Bones semaines c'est quoi
qui t'a le plus impressionné chez
Richard Marcus dans son destin ou même
en terme de manipulation de carartes ou
dans son parcours le culot qu'il a eu de
tricher à une époque où c'était la mafia
qui gérait quand même les casinos à Las
Vegas on risquait pas une amende ou de
la pron enfin du moins c'était pas le
plus grave quoi de risquer une amende ou
de la prison non généralement d'ailleurs
ça se terminait pas comme ça pour les
pour ceux qui nous regardent si s'ils
ont vu le film casino de scorsz c'est
plutôt comme ça que finissait un
tricheur voilà on va pas expliquer
comment mais ça se finissait très mal en
principe très très mal une histoire de
pelle de trou et de désert quoi c'est ça
un petit peu ou voilà ou de main de
casser à coup de marteau ça c'est la
meilleure solution ouais ça c'est ça
c'est c'est on est copain ça ça c'est
quand on est pote ouais on va plus
parler encore après de ton lien avec
Richard de pourquoi on est en train de
parler de lui de comment tu as amener
cette triche là à Vegas mais mais
Richard lui Marcus il avait il s'est
autoormé il il avait été formé par
quelqu'un comment on devient tricheur
comme Richard Marcus par exemple il
vivait du côté euh du côté de New York
en fait et à l'âge de 18 18 ans ouais 18
ans il est parti à Las Vegas pour faire
fortune il a essayé de gagner sa vie en
jouant dans les casinos et puis il s'est
vite aperçu que en principe c'est le
casino qui gagne donc il a il a eu des
petits soucis financiers et du coup il
s'est cherché un job il est devenu
croupier donc ça c'est assez drôle quand
même parce que cté de la barrière de
l'utre côté barrière donc croupier et
tout de suite ben forcément il y en
avait qui le regardait faire dont un
certain Joe leson qui a été son mentor
on a tous des mentors et ça a été son
mentor lui il était à la tête d'une
équipe de tricheurs ce garslà donc il a
reé rich en mod celui-là il on va le
prendre dans la team c'est ça exactement
il a repéré Richard il l' le pagué après
son service un soir et puis il lui a
proposé d'intégrer la team et il l'a
formé et puis un jour bien sûr il lui a
dit bah maintenant il faut que tu crées
ton ton coup de triche et c'est comme ça
qu'après il a créé le coup de bluff de
Savana OK et et après il a fait sa
carrière comme ça avec il avait toujours
avec lui deux complices en principe deux
complices qui sont toujours en activité
est-ce qu'on t'a déjà toi
demandé de de de d'apprendre à tricher
est-ce que des gens t'ont approché en
disant apprends-moi à tricher mais
vraiment en mode premier degré quoi
alors oui on m'a même on m'a plutôt même
demandé d'intégrer une team ok ouis
ouais vraiment tu parlais c'est des
soirées événement
so dansé de Poitier il y a eu de de gars
qui m'ont attendu à la fin alors très
bien on s'est posé un peu la question
avec le patron du bar ce qu'il voulait
puis ils m'ont abordé il m'ont dit voilà
est-ce que ça t'intéresserait d'aller
jouer au poker avec nous donc oui
c'està-dire non parce que voilà on
pourrait monter une on pourrait monter
une équipe et puis et puis aller bah
arnaquer des gens au poker j'ai non j'ai
dit non merci parce que là après ça
rigole plus quand même quoi faut faire
attention à ce que l'on fait donc toi
ton ton spectacle tu l'as joué à Poitier
à La Rochelle et cetera puis à Paris on
en parlait à la cible puis à Avignon la
porortricheur et un tourné durant 2 ans
oui ça marche le spectacle s'appelle
tricheur il reprend l'histoire de
Richard Marcus comme tu l'exliquais tout
à l'heure donc il y a toute une histoire
qui est soutenue en fait par des effets
magiques qui viennent démontrer et
nourrir l'histoire mais l'histoire peut
vivre sans ces effets là mais ça rend le
spectacle assez unique assez particulier
jusqu'à un jour
tu es en tourné tu reçois un mail de
Richard Mercus en personne tu le connais
pas à cette époque là tu sais même pas
que lui a pu entendre parler de toi un
jour qu'est-ce qu'il te dit dans ce mail
il me dit qu'il n'est pas content
voilà voilà voilà euh je me souviens
très très bien j'étais rentré de la vine
du festival d'ailleurs c'était ça fait
un petit mois 2016 26 août 2016tival
d'avenir ouais voilà et il est pas
content du tout il apprend qu'il y a un
spectacle qui se fait sur son sur sa vie
et donc il commence à me dire bah qu'il
faut arrêter qu'il va m'envoyer sa horde
d'avocat et cetera et cetera donc bien
sûr je flippe un peu les deux premières
personnes que j'appelle et bien la
première est en face de moi c'est toi et
France France évidemment qui est aussi
Couteur de ce spectac voilà c'est ça et
moi je me souviens que tu étais
complètement paniqué ah oui oui
totalement paniqué et et même désespéré
hein tu t'es dit c'est c'est foutu c'est
fini fin oui c'est ça c'est ça c'est on
lui propose grosso modo euh bah
peut-être tu peux raconter toi
d'ailleurs les étapes ben on vous lui
proposer d'abord vous me confirmez enfin
vous me confirmez vous me dites bah oui
c'est lui pourquoi tu veux que ça soit
qui d'autre alors moi je pensais à je
sais pas je sais pas quoi une usurpion
d'identité pour pour peut-être
mextorquer des fonds voilà c'est ça
ouais et vous me dites bah non ben c'est
lui pourquoi ça serait quelqu'un d'autre
d'accord ok et puis de là ben on a
discuté avec lui on a échangé avec lui
par mail
tous les deux vous m'avez beaucoup aidé
je sais que tu as laissé faire France tu
m'as dit bah écoute je veille je suis là
vois avec Francez France me faisait les
mails ensemble et puis on a échangé avec
Richard on s'était mis d'accord avec
Franz sur un truc on s'était dit de
toute manière il peut pas faire
grand-chose oui c'est ça il a pas le
droit à grand-chose et on se dit avec
Francez on va nous aussi faire notre
coup de bluff on va jouer dans sa partie
on va dire il y a pas de problème en
fait votre nom et votre histoire elle
est pas très importante pour le
spectacle on va imper un person effectif
on va modifier deux trois détails de
l'histoire et on vous citera plus il y a
pas de souci parce que France et moi on
se dit un peu ce qu'on parlait là tout à
l'heure c'est pas qu'il a pas envie
qu'on parle de lui tu vois et de son
histoire il veut juste ça part du gâteau
en fait et de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique il a l'impression qu'il y a
un gâteau qui est monumental avec de la
crème qui dégouine de tous les côtés
alors que au final on a un spectacle
d'un Maurice qui tourne mais qui déploie
énormément d'énergie pour que ce
spectacle existe c'est pas une grosse
production
donc tu lui proposes par mail après de
retirer son nom et là comment il réagit
bah il me dit il me répond très
gentiment ah non non non non non faut
laisser mon nom et cetera au contraire
faut continuer à en parler mais mais il
faut payer des droits quoi et donc bah
on lui fait la proposition que nous
avons faite qui était très an deess de
voilà était beaucoup plus proche de ce
que ça valait
voilà et puis et puis ça c'est et ça
s'est signé comme ça quoi et ça s'est
signé comme ça une question de droit et
tout le monde était content en fait tout
à fait tout à fait tout à fait donc toi
tu continues son spectacle en tourné
jusqu'au moment où Richard Marcus
tannonce qu'il va venir en France pour
voir le spectacle ce qu'il faut dire
c'est qu'après les échanges de mail où
il m'a mis le coup de pression il m'a
refait un mail alors on a eu une petite
vision ensemble où j'ai eu un gros coup
de pression aussi et après il m'a fait
un mail vraiment d'excuses gentiment en
me disant ouais je suis désolé j'ai eu
une journée compliquée et cetera qui
s'était un peu excusé en me disant je
suis désolé pour le coup de pression
mais il est bien probable qu'un jour je
vienne voir ton spectacle il me raconte
une anecdote et cetera et puis ça s'est
terminé comme ça et effectivement en
2019 en mars il me contacte en me disant
qu'il vient en Europe et qu'il veut voir
tricheur qu'est-ce que ça fait de savoir
que le plus grand tricheur de tous les
temps va venir voir ton spectacle
qu'est-ce qu'on ressent qu'est-ce qu'on
pense à ce moment-là bah on se dit mince
je fais pas Avignon cette année bah oui
ah oui tu le jouais pas c oui c'est
parce que je je t' je t'appelle
d'ailleurs à ce moment-là et je t'ai dis
on fait quoi mais là tu dit à part louer
un créneau à Avignon sur une relâche
mais ça va être compliqué et puis c'est
là que je te fais la je te fais part du
fait que j'étais sur un festival de
magie à Saint-Palais sur mer et c'est là
que tu m'as dit bah faut que tu le
fasses venir à Saint-Palais et donc
c'est ce que nous avons fait je l'ai
convié à Saint-Palais et il est venu
voir le spectacle à Saint-Palais sur mer
et c'est votre première rencontre
physique du coup et c'est notre première
rencontre physique ouais tout à fait à
Saint-Palais et donc ben je vais les
chercher à la gare et c'est marrant
parce que quand il est arrivé on s'est
serré dans les bras comme si on se
connaissait depuis 20 ans quoi et puis
ben les tout de suite la rencontre se
passe super bien on se dit bon je me dis
ça va bien se passer ces premiers mots
ça a été al ça a été mais dis-moi
qu'est-ce que tu fais ton métier c'est
quoi tu es illusioniste c'est quoi parce
qu'il parle comme ça avec un accent
comme ça bah j'ai dis oui je suis
illusioniste bon ok d'accord me dit j'ai
une idée tu vas arrêter ça et il dit on
va monter une équipe et il dit on va on
va faire les casinos en France et ah non
non je dis on va pas faire ça en fait
c'est génial on va déjà faire le
spectacle puis après on va en reparler
hein voilà donc là clairement tu me dis
le plus grand tricheur de tous les temps
arrive en Europe te rends compte et dit
on va monter une équipe on va dépouiller
la France c'est ça c'est ça c'est ça
c'est c'est ses premières phrases
véridiqu he c'est ce qu'il a dit c'est
c'est drôle quoi du coup il assiste à la
représentation de tricheur donc il voit
la prestation artistique toi que tu
pratiques de la triche et de son
histoire tout à fait comment tu te sens
pendant la représentation pas tant de
pression que ça en fait ouais tu l'as
isolé tu as fait ton métier à ce
moment-là oui exactement ouais tu sais
on arrive à on a ce côté-là on en avait
parlé une fois on a ce côté où on arrive
à se détacher un peu et à se dire bon
bah je joue quoi je fais mon métier je
le fais du mieux possible le retour
après le spectacle de mon épouse de
Nélis ça a été tuas je crois que c'est
la meilleure représentation que tuai
jamais fait très concentré qu'elle dit
ouais très concentré tout était propre
nickel qu'est-ce qu'il a pensé du
spectacle il a été totalement bluffé dit
j'ai été
bluffé j'ai vu ma vie sous mes yeux
dérouler alors ça il a été impressionné
par ça parce que conscience de ce que ça
pouvait faire à quelqu'un d'entendre sa
propre vie mise en scène mais ça fa
ouais c'est assez bizarre ouais parce
que je me dis il est là je raconte sa
vie et puis je le vois c'est bizarre
parce qu'en plus normalement on voit pas
le public mais je sais pas comment la
lumière
était je le distinguais il était pas
très loin il était au 3e ou 4e rang il y
avait des moments où quand je je
racontais les choses il a quiessé de la
tête comme ça ah incroyable alors sur
des choses hy per pero de sa vie sur
d'autres trucs moins drôles donc c'est
assez fort quoi on se dit waouh je colle
bien quand même à la à la vie du du
bonhomme quoi donc ému touché mais
bluffé par contre par la technique ouais
tout à fait là on est bloqué aux
alentirs de 2019 mais en 2022 Richard te
contacte vous AZ gardé le contact hein
mais là il te recontacte pour te
proposer quelque chose qu'est-ce que
c'est dit écoute faut qu'on s'appelle
j'ai un super truc pour toi mais faut
qu'on s'appelle al française tu me
donnes un horaire je lui donne un
horaire il m'appelle donc très content
et il m'a dit bon écoute mais il m'a dit
là j'ai un super truc pour toi mais tu
me dis oui tout de suite alors dire oui
tout de suite c'est bien mais quand on
connaît le bonhomme on se dit qu'est-ce
qu'il va me demander quoi encore une
fois et ben je réponds oui as déjà
ouvert un coffre for voilà c'est ça donc
je réponds oui bien sûr et là il est
enthousiaste il me dit ah super tu vas
venir jouer ton spectacle à Las Vegas et
là benis plus de son plus d'image quoi
parce que là je me dit mais pardon euh
donc toi là concrètement il te dit tu
vas jouer dans dans un casino très
célèbre l'excalibure c'est ça casino ou
d'ailleurs si je dis pas de ce st David
coppperfield c'est produit là-bas je
crois qu'il a joué maintenant il est au
MGM Grand ouis mais longtemps
tu c'est un lieu qui a vu passer quand
même certain nom est-ce que un jour tu
avais ne serait-ce que rêveré comme
étant peut-être possible avec beaucoup
de chance de jouer l'un de tes
spectacles et particulièrement celui-ci
à Las Vegas ou vraiment ça rentrait même
pas dans tes radars de rêve tellement
c'était impossible non
non ouais c'est ça en 2015 quand tu m'as
dit bah tu vas faire Avignon je t'ai dis
mais non mais Avignon c'est pas pour moi
et tu m'as dit si si donc là non
j'imaginais même pas un jour aller jouer
à Las Vegas non non jamais c'est fou
parce que tu sais tout à l'heure je
disais en rigolant donc on est bien
d'accord un petit mec à Poitier qui
bosse ses techniques de triche et là
regarde le temps de notre conversation
on finit avec un spectacle à la glire du
plus grand tricheur de tout tous les
temps qui t'a mis un coup de pression à
cause de ce spectacle mais qui a généré
une amitié et tu vas jouer ton spectacle
de triche à Végas qui est une
consécration à soi mais qui veut dire à
quel point Richard a estimé ta technique
de triche parce que c'est sûr qui va
être devant tu vas jouer devant ses amis
des professionnels de la sécurité des
gens comme ça aussi du grand public si
tu es nul si ta technique est pas
terrible c'est Richard qui vont allumer
ils vont dire bah là dis donc ton
français qui qu'est-ce que que tu nous
as fait voir là donc je je trouve aussi
que c'est un marqueur tu vois je sais
pas si tu l'as conscientisé comme ça ou
ou si tu t'en rends compte encore
aujourd'hui mais lui-même prenait un
risque de réputation en fais en venir
tout à fait surtout que bah on sent que
c'est un joueur en fait il leur a
proposer le spectacle c'était OK sur
l'organisation et cetera mais il ne
connaissait pas du tout mais du tout le
le contenu du spectacle en fait il leur
a dit ouis c'est un spectacle sur
l'histoire de Las Vegas sur l'histoire
de la triche à Las Vegas et quand j'ai
commencé le spectacle euh en anglais sur
en disant c'est je vais vous raconter
l'histoire de Richard Marcus et tout le
monde a applaudi ETF voilà il était très
content parce qu'il aura fait la
surprise en fait il le savait pas ah ok
donc ça c'est assez drôle quoi ce moment
a été assez fort quand même quoi donc on
est le 4 juin 2022 ça décolle pour Vegas
tu te sens comment dans l'avion prêt
inquiet heureux on a qu'à faire
demi-tour et rentrer à Poitier c'est ça
mais là c'est pas facile donc on fait
pas marche arrière ouais c'est la
sensation est très bizarre tout va
s'enchaîner et puis bah maintenant je
peux plus reculer quoi donc c'est dans
la tête c'est ça quoi je le dis pas mais
au plus profond de moi-même je flippe un
peu quand même il était comment ce
public à Vegas génial ouais génial bah
les Américains sont très très expressifs
sont très c'est une légende alors non
c'est pas une légende c'est vrai tu fais
un truc impressionnant il il renvoie de
manière sonore et physique que c'était
impressionnantou ouais tout à fait ouais
c'est quoi le moment qui t'a le plus
marqué à Vegas dans ton show ou en
dehors de ton show je découvre un
Richard Marcus différent comme je l'ai
connu de la France c'est qu'il est chez
lui quoi dans son bocal euh ouais il y a
une queue pas possible à la réception il
y a quand même une réception qui fait je
sais pas mais 50 m de longue enfin c'est
immense quoi et il passe devant tout le
monde et il parle fort et cetera et je
dis mais Richard non non mais viens
viens mon pote t'inquiète t'inquiète et
en fait il se fiche de tout quoi c'est
un vrai tricheur quoi c'est que c'est il
se fout tout quoi vraiment il ne suit
que sa propre déontologie de pour moi
c'est que c'est le bien c'est bien voilà
c'est ça donc on est super bien reçu ai
de voir ce spectacle là c'est un
spectacle aussi c'est un spectacle aussi
et donc là bah voilà il nous il nous
prend nos chambres et tout on s'installe
et et puis ça y est c'est parti le
séjour commence quoi donc ça ouais c'est
un très très bon souvenir un souvenir
très marquant quoi ouais après avoir
étudié toute la vie de Richard Marcus
pour écrire le spectacle après avoir
endosser sa peau parce que quand tu es
sur scène il y a des moments où tu es le
narrateur de sa vie mais il y a des
moments où tu incarnes Richard marque
quand même sur scène après l'avoir
rencontré en Europe puis avec gaz dans
son propre univers à lui qu'est-ce que
tu retiendras vraiment de lui qu'est-ce
qui t'impressionne le plus ou qu'est-ce
qui te marque le plus chez lui chez
lui je je crois que c'est sa façon de sa
façon d'aborder la vie comme il le fait
quoi c'est quelqu'un qui qui prend la
vie à bralcor quoi ouais il peut faire
des Hines à tout instant quoi ouais
ouais en fait c'est la vie c'est c'est
un jeu quoi enfin c'est voilà il y va
tout le temps à fond quoi c'est il
cherche pas à comprendre si je dézoome
très loin aujourd'hui avec l'expérience
accumulée tu donnerais quoi comme
conseil à un magicien débutant un
magicien débutant ben de savoir
s'entourer d'écouter les autres et de
lorsqu'on ne sait pas faire quelque
chose faut aller chercher quelqu'un qui
sait le faire et puis de regarder devant
lui de pas regarder ce qui se passe à
droite ou à gauche je connais quelqu'un
qui m'a conseillé comme ça il est pas
loin de moi parce qu'il est juste en
face c'est toi ouais regarde droit
devant toi tu m'as toujours dit t'occupe
pas pas de ce qui se passe à gauche à
droite fais ton taf et c'est vrai oui
c'est c'est c'est c'est selon moi c'est
une compétition où chacun court sur son
propre terrain donc ne court que contre
lui-même en faitité voà c'est c'est quoi
ton regard aujourd'hui sur la magie
actuelle si tu as un regard tu vois
est-ce que est-ce que tu trouves que bah
non je vais pas te donner de piss est-ce
que tu as un regard toi sur la magie
actuelle je trouve que la magie elle
vend en poupe ça c'est plutôt pas mal
c'est vrai elle elle est bien remonté de
ce côtél c'est ouais voilà ouais plus
plus on voit de à la télé ou sur les
réseaux c'est super parce que du coup on
parle de on parle de notre art du coup
bah on a envie de nous engager après on
se dit ah bah tiens regarde on a vu sur
les réseaux tel magicien et cetera
serait peut-être bien qu'on prenne un
magicien pour l'entreprise moi je dis
que c'est bien je trouve que c'est ouais
si c'est bien c'est pas mal
quoi c'est de plus en plus fréquent
aussi de voir des personnes comme toi
qui ramènent un spectacle dont la magie
est un outil du spectacle et qui ont
aussi compris la notion globale de
spectacle et pas juste des tours pour
des tours donc c'est estce que tu serai
d'accord pour terminer d'une un
mouvement un geste j'ai du mal à
utiliser le mot démonstration mais juste
un petit truc qui nous fasse dilater la
pupille sur cette fin de vidéo c'est
possible ben écoute allez pourquoi pas
en avant je l'ai dit au tout début de la
vidéo mais il y a un livre qui est sorti
où il y a toute ton histoire avec plein
de détails qu'on n pas abordé
aujourd'hui toute l'histoire complète de
de ce spectacle là tricheur qui est
incroyable à lire qui est sorti en livre
dans un livre où il y a aussi plein de
techniques que tu utilises dont tu
parles il y a aussi un DVD avec des des
des illustrations et des images
d'archives aussi de de l'époque tout ça
c'est c'est édité par France ton Couteur
qui est un éditeur très connu dans notre
milieu dans le milieu de la magie du
mentalisme de la triche et cetera et ça
quand même faut le savoir c'est c'est
c'est des livres de très très beau
livres qui demandent beaucoup de travail
et qui sont vendus pour un petit marché
donc qui sont plus chers que ce qu'on a
l'habitude d'avoir et France quand il a
su qu'on allait faire cette vidéo il a
dit bah si tu veux je donne un code pour
les personnes qui suivent si vous voulez
ce livre je vous mettrai le lien dans la
description mais mais France du coup a
créé un code c'est Fabien mon prénom en
minuscule et ça vous donne 20 € de
réduction sur le livre complet avec le
DVD et cetera et cet ah c'est cool ouais
c'est chouette l'idée que j'ai c'est je
me dis j'utilise ce jeu je vais aller
chercher l'ASS de cœur très bien je vais
mettre l'ASS de cœur en première
position on imagine on a une table de
poker je suis ton complice ouais tu dois
distribuer les cartes moi je suis en 4e
position 4e d'accord donc je dois
recevoir l' d'accord déjà été mélangé il
a déjà été coupé là c'est dessus et
c'est moi qui donne tu n'as pas d'autre
possibilité que de donner il faut
absolument que tu me serves la 104e je
sais que tu sais faire des grands
classiques de la magie mais grand
classique veut pas dire simple c'est
très très dur à pour le coup tout tout à
fait ok donc je récupère On est tu es tu
es en 4e d'accord donc on fait une 2 3
et voilà c'est pour toi et c'estas et
c'estas c'est rigolo il y a les cadrur
derrière de il sont en train de de rire
en serrant la mâchoire tu tu tu veux
bien nous le faire voir sur le tapis
directement qu'on suive un peu donc là
c'est dessus hein ouais on est on est
d'accord je vais je vais distribuer tu
me dis stop quand tu veux bah leï tiens
dis stop ah on peut refaire ou loï tu
dis stop quand tu
veux
d'accord c'est la première rigolo c'est
la première en fait hein tu veux
peut-être que je te montre en fait
comment ça fonctionne on terminera
là-dessus on terminera là-dessus je je
en fait je vous emène de l'autre côté du
miroirouis tu laisses je la mets voilà
visible et en fait voilà ce qui se
passe si je ralentis voilà ce qui se
passe je décale la première carte je
fais ce qu'on appelle une donne seconde
donc tu donnes toujours la deuxième
voilà et donc là quand j'ai fait bah
première deuxè 3e et je t'ai envoyé la
4e ce au-delà du geste technique et
d'une précision millimétréee ce qui me
fascine c'est j'imagine que c'est le
plus important pour les tricheurs tu as
le même rythme que tu donnes la bunne ou
que tu donnes l'autre tout à fait ça qui
est fascinantouis tout à fait bon écoute
je comprends pourquoi Richard t'a
proposé de faire une équipe je suis de
vous financer moi génial on y va on a
beaucoup de chance que Maurice était si
généreux pour nous raconter toute
l'histoire je trouve ça très inspirant
sachez également que l'interview à la
table existe la forme d'un podcast qui
s'appelle interview à la table qui est
disponible sur Spotify 10h Apple podcast
Google podcast un petit peu partout vous
avez les rediffusion en audio de ce que
vous pouvez suivre ici sur la chaîne et
des interviews supplémentaires à très
bientôt Ciao